finances publiques fiscalité soutien aux
ménages ce que vous devez savoir ce soir
à partir de maintenant notre invité luc
godbout titulaire de la chaire de
recherche en fiscalité et en finances
publiques de l'université de sherbrooke
bonsoir luc godbout
bonsoir on a divisé en fait vous nous
proposez de diviser cela en trois
parties pour bien comprendre les
propositions est ce qu'il faudra
surveiller la partir de maintenant
compte tenu des problèmes finances
publiques d'abord des déficits et des
déficits c'est ce qui devrait voir sa
des 17 plus important que prévu devant
le directeur parlementaire du budget
prévoyait des déficits pour les quatre
prochaines années
les libéraux font près de 6 93 milliards
de déficit pour les quatre prochaines
années ces trente deux milliards de plus
que les boyer directeur parlementaire du
budget donc c'est important comme comme
comme changement de situation
c'est dans le cadre financier d'ailleurs
pas de surprise mais c'est vraiment ce
qui était ce qui était prévu par les
libéraux augmenté les déficits pour
faire plus de dépenser 10 et qui dit
augmenter le déficit dit augmenter la
dette absolue est ce qu'il y aura un
effet sur les intérêts à payer
il ya deux éléments qui pour lequel il
va avoir un intérêt un effet sur les
intérêts premièrement les libéraux dans
leurs comptes financiers n'y ont pas
budgété des internationales découlant de
l'endettement actionnaires donc des gens
partant ça va créer une pression déjà
sur le déficit pour qu'ils soient plus
élevés c'est un trou dans le cadre final
c'est un trou dans le cadre financier
les organisateurs du parti dit que le
déficit additionnel était pour stimuler
l'économie que ça ferait un des rentrées
fiscales qui était pour ricky valoir aux
intérêts sur les billets c'est un risque
que ça mais un cadre transparent ont
remis des intérêts sur la dette
additionnels comme trois partis l'ont
fait dans le cas de la campagne est
l'autre élément c'est que les intérêts
sur la dette sont déjà en augmentation
si on prend depuis 2010 est à 2000 2003
on prévoyait vous déjà d'un gouvernement
pour le budget fédéral d augmentation de
plus de 50% des intérêts sur mes dettes
au cours de ces années là en dépit du
fait que les intérieurs actuellement
sont extrêmement beau tant que ça va
créer une pression additionnelle sur
augmenter les intérêts de la part des
intérêts dans le budget
on est dans un contexte de gouvernement
minoritaire les libéraux ne seront pas
freiné parce que le npd par exemple dans
ce cadre financier prévoyait 85
milliards de d'ici tout à fait alors son
lot on l'a déjà vu qu'il ya eu d'autres
gouvernements minoritaires que ce soit
des alliances ponctuelles entre le npd
et les libéraux de paul martin qui avait
entraîné des dépenses additionnelles
dans le logement social ou d'autres
éléments et donc ça oui sérieuse des
réservoirs ses alliances là il s'écrit
toujours une pression additionnelle sur
les dépenses généralement c'est pas
moins de dépenser toujours plus de
dépenses donc une pression encore une
fois sur l'enjeu du déficit budgétaire
deuxième grand thème la fiscalité la
fiscalité la principale promesse c'est
une baisse d'impôts avec la majoration
du montant personnel de base
oui donc lorsqu'on les libéraux
prévoyait c'est augmenter
progressivement le montant personnel de
base pour qu'il soit plus généreux et
que dans quelques années il est en 15000
dollars dont le premier 15000 dollars de
revenus déjà serait libre d'impôt dans
la mesure où il y aurait un crédit qui
effacerait l'impôt à payer ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que ça se met en place
progressivement ça coûte déjà
extrêmement cher on parle de 5 6
milliards par année une fois mises en
place mais c'est pas une mesure
universelle pour autant donc au delà
d'un certain seuil
la majoration du montant personnel de
base va s'effacer progressivement donc
si on appliquait cette année passée sans
48000 la majoration s'effacerait jusqu'à
210 milles de revenus et tous les gens
qui gagnent 2 cm de plus de revenus
annuellement n'aurait pas droit cette
majoration là donc on vise les moins
nantis la classe moyenne la casse
moyenne élevée parce que les gens plus
un mieux nantis ne profiterait pas de
cette veste c'est dans la logique du
gouvernement libéral de justin trudeau
il y avait un cinquième taux qui était
juste ajouter aux dernières élections
mais dès lors qu'on va arriver à ce
cinquième tome leur n'aurait pas du tout
la majoration du montant personnel de
base
le parti libéral du canada a aussi
proposé de taxer les biens de luxe taxe
de 10%
encore une fois il va pas avoir une
accointance avec le parti si le npd dans
ressourcerie npd voulait taxer les gens
à revenus élevés donc les biens de luxe
sont associés aux gens aux revenus
élevés
on parle de taux de bateaux d'air
f dès lors que ça coûte plus de 100
mille dollars il y aura une taxe de 10%
qui s'appliquerait à l'achat de ces
biens de luxe le troisième point sur la
fiscalité et c'est là qu'on va aller
chercher des revenus supplémentaires
puis qu'il reportait du travail à faire
très sérieux les géants du web qu'on
veut taxer davantage trouvé les
échappatoires fiscales les combler et
réviser certaines mesures fiscales en
parlant des géants du web déjà pour les
libéraux il ya un petit volte-face là du
côté de la tipp et la tps
donc la taxe netflix qu'on appelait donc
ils veulent associative ces géants du
web la à la taxe de vente lorsque les
ventes sont faits ici est l'autre
élément on parle d'appliquer un peu une
taxe gars folle sur le chiffre
d'affaires lorsqu'elle est en lien avec
le chiffre d'affaires réalisé au canada
on veut appliquer une taxe de 3%
c'est bien de savoir si c'est une bonne
taxe mais ça maintient la pression tant
et aussi longtemps que l' ocde arrivera
pas qu'une solution plus globale
ça maintient la pression sur les jeunes
du web pour dire on vous a à l'oeil on
veut aller chercher notre part de
recettes fiscales en lien aux activités
que vous faites sur notre territoire
voilà c'est pour les échappatoires
fiscales ben là c'est ça vise les
entreprises donc là on vise vraiment les
entreprises on veut resserrer les règles
puis pour des mesures fiscales ont
également resserré les règles puissent
quand même des grosses où l'on parle
pour les entreprises de resserrement de
à peu près 1 1 milliard et demi puis
pour les mesures fiscales en général on
veut un resserrement de 3 milliards dont
c'est quand même beaucoup de sous qui
sont en jeu le bain les ménages
maintenant famille est né l'enjeu de
l'assurance médicaments également les
familles d'abord la location pour les
enfants de moins d'un an sera bonifié
oui tout à fait donc il ya déjà la
location canadienne pour enfants que les
libéraux ont mis en place autour de 2016
on veut majoré l'année de la naissance
on veut majoré de 15%
la location donc on donnerait dans le
fond un ménage que nouvel enfant 1000 $
de plus que dans la situation actuelle
pour les gens avec les revenus les plus
faibles on parle de pour un enfant
les saint denis à l'occasion de cette
1750 $ du gouvernement fédéral donc
c'est des sommes quand même significatif
on a aussi exonération des prestations
parentales donc on veut exonérer les
prestations parentales
donc ça c'est un nouveau changement qui
a rejoint un peu les conservateurs comme
une mesure similaire également donc ça
rejoint cette idée là de pendant l'année
de la vie de l'enfant à aider les
familles à joindre les deux bouts
on verra pour l'assurance médicaments si
ça va vraiment se développer je veux
qu'on termine sur les années les
prestations de la sécurité de la
vieillesse qui sera bonifié sur et donc
bonifier au delà de 75
c'est ça faut bien retenir c'est pour
les aînés de 75 ans et plus si vous
recevez un chèque actuellement pour
l'année 2019 d'à peu près 7000 300 $ si
vous avez 75 ans et plus les majorations
va faire en sorte que vous allez
atteindre 8000 $ par année donc c'est
quand même un mort une bonification
significative juste ça pour les 75 ans
et plus après ciblées ça va coûter à
terme par année 2 milliards de plus
quand même donc vrai quand même le garde
en tête et plusieurs de ces mesures
serait dans le premier budget du mois de
mars
mais comme ce gouvernement minoritaire
il ya intérêt remplir ses promesses le
plus rapidement possible sur tous les
promesses font consensus en termes de
dépenses additionnelles avec un ami qui
pourra être le npd dans ce cas là le
godbout merci beaucoup merci au revoir